Yle Areena.
(Musiikkia)
- Ah, mikä ihanaa onni minua kohtasi tässä. Eilen olin laittamassa kolmea kananmunaa jääkahpi ja kaksi putosi lattialle.
Mutta onneksi ne oli keitettyjä kananmunia ja sopivasti se putous rikkoi niiden kuorta ja olipahan paljon helpompi sitten kuoria ja hyvältä ne maistu. Kaikkea hyvää. Keittäkää kananmunia ja syökää. Niissä on ravintoa. Heippa!
- No onneksi ne tosiaan olivat keitettyjä. Kananmuniin palataan tässä omassa myöhemminkin. Nyt kiitos ensimmäiselle soittajalle.
- Ja jälleen on aika sanoa perinteisesti eli tervetuloa mukaan ja matkaan. Tässä jaksossa pääsemme ainakin jääkiekon, ruuan ja ylioppilaiden maailmaan. Kansanradion kevätjuhlan kuoronjohtajana toimii Koiviston Lauri. Yksi soittaja vaatii teitittelyä takaisin. Toinen kansalainen taasen ehdottaa kasinoja Ahvenanmaalle ja pyydetäänpä myös peräkammarinpoidelle lisää tv-ohjelmia.
Nyt ajatuksia pariin viime aikojen polttavaan puheenaiheeseen. - Ihmettelen, ihmettelen suuresti tästä Riivimäen tapauksesta kun ilmoitetaan että sellainen ja sellainen granaatti on pellosta löyhtynyt niin kolmen viikkoa meni ennen kuin se tuli ja poistettiin. Ihmettilen minä, ihmettelen. Mikä mättää oikein? Niin vaarallinen kuin granaation. Sitten kehutaan että siitä nyt joku. Kyllä se nyt joku poistaa.
Siitäkin kun pellolla on granaatti niin ei, ei johonakin on mältä. Kehutaan ettei saa sattua. Ilmoitetaan viranomaiselle niin ei toimita. Kolmen viikkoa mennään ennen kuin se toimitaan. Minä kuuntelin rasiosta siitä päivällä. Ei multa. Tältä polojamatta samppa voi.
On aika masentavaa huomata että täällä yhteydenkunnassa muodostetaan sääntöjä ja kieltoja ja ja ja halutaan tietysti fiskallisesti toimia vähän joka paikassa mutta se taju asioista jää hiukan niin kuin varjoon.
Jos me kiellettiin parveketupakointi sen takia että sitä haju tunkeutuu muihin huoneistoihin niin miksei kerta kaikkiaan sitten kielletty parvekkeella kaikenlainen tulen käsittely.
Selvä asia että josta grillimakkarasta laadusta riippuen tulee semmoinen kärvi johon tupakankärvi on aivan jotain lasten leikkiä. Sitten toinen juttu ei siellä parvekkeella hyvä polttaa kynttilöitäkään jos se unohtuu palaamaan ja siellä on jotakin palavaa tai uutta niin palaahan se siellä samalla tavalla kuin mikä muu tuhi tahansa. Eikä kokonaisvaltaisuutta tässäkin olisi tarvittu tässä ohjeistuksessa. Parvekki on osa sitä asuntoa jonka käytössä se on ja riippuu ihan.
Niistä ihmisistä kuin huolellisesti siellä on. Miten enemmän annetaan valtuuksia sitä enemmän ne tietysti sitten huolimattomasti siellä touhuavat. Eli kyllä tätä taas viranomaisia pitää katsoa peiliin että olisivat nyt tajuneet sen verran että siellä muukin tulen käyttö kielletään kuin se tukanomuus.
Kansanradion sähköpostiosoite sun muitten sirenejä pitäisi hiljentää. On kamalaa kun yrittää nukkua ja joku punainen kajutin laatikko ajaa pillit huutaen ikkunan ohi siniset valotkin pääsevät verhoeni läpi. Heidän pitäisi vähintään jakaa kaikille reitillä asuville korvatulpat jotta saisin nukkua hyvin. Kiitos ja kumarus. Näin lukee sähköpostissa jonka on lähettänyt esimerkki Etelän markki. Kansanradion sähköpostiosoite on kansan.radio.fi.
Täältä porssasta hei täällä on keskisen yksi piste ikkunat auki nyt kun että kesätuulähdys tulee ei tule tuudaustat tulee naapurin tupakat ja jolle olen allerginen niin pitää kai muuttaa pois kun ei. Ei saa olla niin kuin pitäisi saada olla kunnolla avata ikkunat niin minäkin avaan mutta nyt vaan ei voi. En halua savutella. Kiitos hei.
No terve, se on Mikko Tadan Lapillaan, että soittelen. Mä juuri tuossa kuuntelin taas jälleen kerran yhden Kanta-radiojakson ja koko jakso taas eläkkeestä puhuttiin, mutta sitä mä vaan ihmettelin itse, että miten ees kestäävät näistä eläkkeistä valittaa samaan aikaan kun minä itse opiskelen oikeuspiedettä. Ja sanotaanko näin, että tiedä ehkä yhteiskunnan järjestelmistä pikkusen enemmän kuin rivisoitteen? Samaan aikaan opiskelijoille maksetaan 500 euroa kuussa tukiaisiä ja sitten samaan aikaan
kansanradio soittaa ja tunnetusti eläkeläisille, paitsi tietenkin pientulosimmille, mutta suurimmalle osalle maksetaan useita tuhansia euroja, mutta minun vuokrani on päälle 700 euroa, tukijaa on 500 euroa, kun taas sitten eläkeläiset saavat tuhansia euroja ja niin päin pois. Tätä vaan ihmettelee ääne. Kiitos ja mukavaa kesäijaa.
Kansanradiossa erää souva puhui ilmassa olentavista autoista. Niistä on nyt puhuttu aikaisemminkin, mutta tuli mieleeni vaan sitäkään varten niitä kannattaisi laittaa, ettei tarvitse sitten teiden kuntoon laittaa rahaa. Jos ilma Kuoppia on, niin niitähän ei voi paikata niin kuin maantietä, jossa tahtoa on siihen. Eipä tässä muuta. Kiitos, hei.
Niin kun ottiin jotain tutkuetta vastaan, oltiin osoittamassa mieltä, vaikka siellä aivan rauhallisesti käveltiin. Jos on ajatellut osallistuvansa neutraaliin rauhanomaiseen vappukulkueeseen, niin minä mietin sitä, että miksi on ollut tarvetta peittää omat kasvot. Onko sitten siinä tapauksessa lukenut tämän Sinimusta liikkeen tavoiteohjelmia? Kyseensähän on avoimesti uusfasistinen liike, eli vaikka marssittaisikin rauhanomaisesti, niin päämäärät hän toiminnassa ei ole rauhanomaisia, eikä varsinkaan rauhanomaisia, jotka ovat rauhanomaisia.
Yhdenvertaisia tai oikeudenmukaisia. Eli kannattaa selvittää, minkälaisiin tapahtumiin, minkälaisia aatteita ajaviin tapahtumiin on osallistumassa, niin ei tarvitse sitten pahoittaa mieltä siitä, että toiset kansalaiset myöskin rauhanomaisesti ovat rauhanomaisia, näyttää, esittää panderolleja ja vastustaa fasistista toimintaa. Väkivaltahan siellä kohdistui nimenomaan näihin vastamielenosoittajiin, joita joukolla pahoinpideltiin kulkujen toimesta.
Että kyllä siinä nytpähän kannattaa katsoa peiliin, että missä toiminnassa se ongelma on.
Pieni koira oli siis yhden tunnin haukkunut, kun on vanha ja yksin kotona ja siitä naapuri tuli valittamaan. Omasta mielestäni naurettavaa valitusta, etenkin pienestä sihukoirasta. Muuttakaa taloon, johon lemmikit eivät ole sallittuja, jos ette kestä. Ymmärrän, jos pitkin yötähaukkuu, mutta tämä kyseinen koira oli keskellä päivää haukkunut. Ei koiria saa kokonaan hiljaisiksi, niinkuin ei ihmisiäkään.
Kansanradion WhatsApp-numero on 044 551 5464.
Multa nyt teki semmoinen mieleen, että totesko meidän tuonne Ahvenanmaalle pistää kasinopys? Kasino Ahvenanmaalle? Mistäs täällä on ne? Useampiakin. Katselet sitä, että se on vähän niin kuin tuommoinen kylkiäinen tossa vieressä, että sinne saat ihan itään vaan kaikki hieno rakennettu. Sinne otti sitä muutaman kasinon ja sit sillä vähän isomman lentokentän ja pistä siitä alueesta kokonaan verovapaa tehdä seikkain. Niinkuin tänne pohjoismainen oli Las Vegas. No siellä käviskään tuo ympäri, tuossa no tänne vietippa tikkuuli nii tuosta yhden, kolmen, neljän, seitsemän.
Neljäisemmän kilometrin säteöti. Lentokoneet lentäis lujaa ajaa edes takaisin ja sieltä perittäis. Tietenkin kato pääsinmaksu alueelle, sitte kaikkee oheismyytiin, mitä muuta sieltä voi tehdäkseni. Kyllähän niin kuin säkkiin tulis työpaikkuri paljon ku ja väkeä riittää siinä varmaan. Kiinnostava ehdotus. Jäädään seuraamaan, että minkälaista kommentteja tämä herättää täällä Kansanradiossa? Joo ja sit semmoset, että laittaa sillä, kun mä tiedän kuitenkin, et sitte sieltä peruna viileilee et muut subut, jotka siel kauan asunut, niin ne suuttuu kaikki. Mut tota.
Sillä tiedäkseni, millähän vois antaa jopa sinun oman kasinoon. Niin. Kiitoksia tästä ja hyvää yöpäivän jatkoa. Samoin sinulle. Hei vaan. No tässä Kanta suomalainen ihminen. Päivä mä ehdotan tässä, että alettais teiti tällä toisinamme, et se vois lisätä semmoset kunnioittavaa asennetta. Kun mä oon nyt miettinyt tässä joka päivä.
Päivä tulee vasta tämmöistä rääväsoista jarkoni ja tulee yleltä viimeksi. Tarkoitan siis sellaista loukkaavaa, alistavaa sanomista toisista kiroilun varjolla, vaikka se ei ole kiroilua, vaan halutaan roukata, että kiroilu on terveellistä. Siis tätä tulee muuhantakin kuin someessa. Siis kaikissa käännöksissä, kirjoissa tulee, että jos sä istut jossain kahvilas, niin eikös siinä viereisessä
siis tuun niinku aikuisilt ihmisilt just näitä loukkaavia sanoja. Niin niin tulis ilmapiiri paremmaksi.
- Tähän loppuu vielä niin kerro että siis missä tilanteessa ihmisten pitäisi teitellään mielestäsi?
- No vieraita ihmisiä toisiaan vaikka no kaupan kassa aloitetaan nyt siitä ja naapuritkin voisi teititellä toisiaan. No mitä Saksasahan ainakin teitteellään?
- Siellä on vahva teitittelykulttuuri kyllä.
- Joo siis kun minua kyllästyttää tällainen siis missään sä et saa olla hyvässä ilmapiirissä. Siis joka päivä tulee tätä vastaan tätä jarkomia ja se ei ole kiroilua vaan se on loukkaamista ja se V on niin yleistynyt meillä et aikuiset täyttää turhaa nuorisosuuttaa.
- Niin mikä tämän kiroilun ja teitittelyn yhteys on että nehän ei liity toisiinsa?
- Onhan se nyt vaikeampi sanoa että te olette V tai te olette et se niin kuin vähentäisi sitä et tulisi kunnioittavampaa. Kyllä siinä on mutta minä ajattelen että voisiko taas olla yhteys jos en mä nyt väitä että mikä lopullinen totuus on mutta kyllä niin kuin häiritsee tollainen kielenkäyttö ja.
- Kiitoksia tästä pohdinnasta ja ehdotuksesta ja jäädään seuraamaan minkälaista keskustelua tämä Kansanradiossa herättää.
- Kiitos hei.
- Nyt on suru uuti sen aika. Meidän olemme pitkäaikainen soittaja lähtemään Jukka Turusta on kuollut. Tämä selvisi viime sunnuntaina kun hänen poikaansa soitti Kansanradion päivystykseen.
- No lähtemään Ville päivää. - Päivää päivää. - Mä vähän soittelen mun isän puolesta kun Jukka lähtemäki aika monesti sinne soiteluaikoinaan. - Niin ja ihan viimeaikoinakin. - Joo kyllä se pitää paikkansa mut nyt kävi semmoinen homma et meidän isä nukkui sunnuntaina pois.
- Ai. - Joo mä aattelin vaan et se ois isälle semmoinen kunnioisuutus et mä soitan teille sinne vaik surullinen asia onkin mut näin kävi mut hän lähti saappaat ja alassa ja ei oo tullu kärsimä. - Otan osaa suuri osanotto. - Joo kiitos paljon mut mä aattelin et se oi mun isä kohtaa semmoinen kunnia et mä aattelin mä ilmotan tänne teillekin sinne. Näin on nyt käyny. - Hienoa kun ilmotit että sä kyllä aina monesti toimituksessa mietitään että jos joku vakiosoittajista ei enää soita ni kiitoksia joku kerroit ja voimia sinne.
- Kiitos paljon ja ei mitään tällästä se elämä on kaikki me lähetään täältä mut koska ei teidän koska lähetään. - Näinhän se on. - Joo mut näillä ei muuta kuin hyvää kevää ja kesä jatkoani. - Kiitos sitä samaa ja tosiaan kaikkea hyvää sinne. - Kiitos paljon moi moi. - Hei hei.
Hallitusta. Heille oli sen iso soketto tekemisen ohessa myös tuli lisäkustannuksiksi. Korona Ukrainan sota ja Nato liittyminen. Nämä kaikki aiheutti kustannuksia joihin myös nämä muut puolueet suostuivat ja nyt sanotaan että ne tekivät paljon ylimääräistä velkaa. Miettikäs vähän mikä oli tilanne jos tämänhetkinen hallitus olisi silloin ollut asialla niin kyllä olisi tullut meille rankat.
Ei ne olisi pärjännyt lainkaan että älkääpä näitä naisia. Nämä olivat urheitatekijöitä vakavissa isoissa teoissa. Moro. - No niin äijä taas Helsingistä soittaa kun on kuudellunut eduskunnan kyselytunteja niin kaikki on aina sen edelleen hallituksen syytä. Minun on pakko tämmöinen henkilökohtainen asia sanoa että fatsa oli niin kova että minä en meinannut saada.
Ulos sitä pönttään. Voisko siitä jotenkin syyttää edellisestä hallitusta että se nyt tuntuu kummalliselta että kyllä minä luulen että se on varmaan edellisen hallituksen syy että oli fatsa niin kovalla että tämmöistä. Eipä muuta kiitos.
Tulemme tuloisimpia eli köyhät kyykkyyn periaatteella vieden jo tuhkatkin pesästä. Kyllä nyt on niin että onnellisten maassa kasvaa nyt pahoinvoiva kansa hallituksemme riistojen myötä. Minä itse en enää kehtaa sanoa olevani suomalainen tässä niin sanotussa onnellisten maassa sillä hävittää kuinka irrokasta on kun täällä näkyvät lapsiperheet ja.
Asunnoistaan häädetään ulos kun ei ole enää työpaikkoja millä perheensä elettäisi. Sama nälkäkuuri ja pahoinvointi sen kun vain lisääntyy viimeisiä hallituksemme päätöksiä kuunnellessa eli moottona maailmalle olemmekin nykyään Euroopan onnettomin ja nälkään näkevin kansa eli siinäkin olemme jälleen ykkösijalla. Ei kyllä hurraa huutoja kuulu.
Aikaansa seuraava kansalainen Sirpa Anneli on tätä mieltä. Toivotaan parempaa jatkoa. Kiitos.
No ennä seppä täällä päivää taas. Miksi minulta otetaan niin vähän veroja. Se on mielenkiintoinen kun ei tällaista asiaa ei saa puhua Suomessa kun minä kysyin kahdelta satalta kansanedustajalta samaa kysymystä että miksi minä voin saada esimerkiksi vuoden aikana seitsemänsataa tuhatta.
Sitten minun ei tarvinnut niistä elämäni aikana koskaan maksaa vero yksikään kansanedustaja ei vastannut kysyksen ja olisi se mukava että tällaisesta asiasta saisi kansanradiossa keskustella. Moi.
Talonkaupungin mettakulmen jatko vaan päivää. Tässä pitää taas herätä ja katsoa sateisen aamu mutta pitää nyt huomauttaa semmoinenkin asia että kun ei orpo saanut sitä tunnijunaa millä ilvellä. Se on suu kuusi miljardin joka tapauksessa mutta kuitenkin nyt sitä laitiovaunu Turkuus on vaan puoli miljardia euroa siihen mutta jos ei nyt sitäkaan saada niin laitetaan hyvät ihmiset sentään keräyksi ja hommataan orpalle oma resina ja.
Puhemuksen väre ja junalaki niin eiks Suomi ole sitten hyvää vetovoimamarkkinoina maailmalle. Terve.
Mikä orpo loppuun niin laittosivat kansanterveydenhoito ja huolto jotta ei rokottaisi niitä vanauksia ja vahatuloisia niin ne on koittakia pitkään nyt sitä viimeisestäkin jereisiveenistä iski jollain eipä muuta sote teemoihin tiemme vie seuraavaksi ennen sitä postikortti jos lukee näin. Hallituksen myöntämät rahoitustuet rakentamiseen tulisi myöntää vain kotimaisille yrityksille jotka työllistävät.
Vain kotimaista työvoimaa näin vero ynnä muut tulot jäävät Suomeen. Ehto koskisi myös aliurakointia. Jokainen työllistetty kotimainen rakentaja mahdollistaa kahdesta kolmeen muuta työntekijää työhön. Tällä tavoin luki kortissa jonka meillä oli esimerkki Arska kirvesmies eläkeläinen. Kansanradio voi lähettää kortteja ja muuta perinteistä postia osoitteeseen. Kansanradio pl seitsemänkymmentäyhdeksän nolla.
Nolla kaksikymmentäneljä Yleisradio. Paljon puhetta mutta ei muutoksia. Hoitoalalle hoitajille takaisin soveltuvuustestit. Käykö hoitajaksi? Kannattaako hakeutua hoitoalalle? Näitä on liian jokaiset. Ajatellaan että hoitoala on hämmentä helppo yksinkertaista ja sitten käykin niin että soveltuvuus kun melkein nollaa. Siellä on erittäin tarkkaasella lääkityksiä.
Haavanhoitoja ja muiden tarkkailua ja mikäli näitä ei kykene hoitamaan niin ei kyllä alalle. Se lisää potilasriskiä, epäselvyyttä ja valitettavasti myöskin että muut hoitajat joutuvat paikkaamaan ja olemaan vastuussa henkilöistä jotka eivät alalle kerta kaikkiaan sovi. Kiitos. Hei. Suuri ihmitys kun Uudellamaalla.
Ei ole terveyskeskusmaksuja. Muu Suomi maksaa kyllä. (Korotan ääniä.)
Ja ne saa välillä vääriäkin diagnoosia ja voisi hakea niinkö vaikka niillä on CRPS-diagnoosi, niin sitten ne annetaan ilman mitään niin tutkimuksiani annetaan toiminnallinen häiriödiagnoosi ja konversiohäiriödiagnoosi.
Niin mitä porukka on mieltä tämmöisestä, että ihmisten hoito jätetään retuperälle tai sitten että heitellään sitä sairaalaista sairaalaan tai jätetään vähänkin pöytälaatikkoon hoitamatta asia ja sitten potila siten saa sitä vaatimalla vaatia,
että se asia menee eteenpäin tai sitten jos se on sitä vanhemmista ihmistä kyse niin sit ne jää kokonaan hoitamatta. Ja mitä mieltä otettaisiin vanhuspuolen hoidosta, ettäkö vanhainkotia laitetaan kiinni ja vanhukset pitäisi olla vaan kotona ja tälleen.
Elikkä lähetetty politiikkaa koskeva viesti. Siinä lukee näin: Meidän politiikot koko ajan nostavat terveyskeskusmaksuja tai vievät köyhiltä, nuorilta tai opiskelijoilta kaikki tuet, mutta yksikään politiikko ei ole puhunut tai puuttunut puoluetukiin. Pitäisikö ne poistaa? Vuonna kaksituhatta kaksikymmentäkuusi puoluetukea maksettiin kolmekymmentäneljä miljoonaa viisataakuusikymmentäkuusi tuhatta euroa. Tällä tavalla luki viestissä, jonka niinku:.
Eli esimerkki Eläkeläinen Vantaalta oli lähettänyt Kansanradion verkkosivujen lomakkeella.
Voittakaa mulle selvittää vaikka ja terveiset MTV:lle ja MTV Kolmoselle ja Elisalle. Mikä raha kerjuu tää on? Kiitos kansalle. Kaikkea hyvää. Moi moi.
Ne löytyy nykyisin hyviä antenneja. Ihan talous sisälle voi laittaa. Niissä on pari metriä johto, että televisiota ainakin siirtämällä. Kun sen antenni saa johonkin ikkunan luokse, niin rupeaa kaikki kanavat näkymään. Tietysti joutuu virittää uudestaan, mutta kyllä siihen aina apu löytyy. Viesti päättyy.
Ennen niitä on paikallaan muistuttaa, että Kansanradion jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan joka perjantai kello kaksikymmentäyksi. Jos merkkaat sydämenkuvasta ja tilaat ohjelmasta ilmoitukset kellonkuvasta, niin saat aina ensimmäisenä tiedon kun uusi jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan.
Elikkä eikä mitään kahden minuutin uutisia, että on ihan tyhjän päivä sellaiset kahden minuutin uutisia. Tietoksi vaan radion ylimmälle johdolle, että muuttakaa uutiset pitkälle ja supistakaa jostain muusta turhemmasta ohjelmasta. Hei!
Mutta eihän minulta koskaan mitään kysytä. Hei hei!
Vai oliko laulun valinnut toimittaja, että tää jäi mietitystämään? Kiitos.
Ei ole enää kun olet yksin eläjäseverin, kun hommas naisen itsellensä. Ja niin kuin eräs legendaarinen meemikin sanoi, niin kun otetaan huomioon, että naiset ovat kuitenkin tilanneet tämän maailman, niin kovin minä mieleli pahotin. Ei ole yksin eläjä severin, enää yksin eläjä, vaan on kaksin eläjä severin. Toivoisinkin Yleisradiolta nyt lisää ohjelmaa meille peräkammarin pojille, meille syrjäkyljen yksinäisille puurtajille.
Ehkä joku tällainen peräkammarin liive, esimerkiksi vähän niin kuin joku norppa liive ja muita näitä. Mutta ei muuta kuin rakkaista, terveisiä kaikkiin suomalaisiin peräkammareihin hyvää kevättä.
Hei, tuli mieleen kun katsoi tuota Ihatut naiset -sarjaa, että kohta miehet syyllistää naisia siitäkin, että kun he eivät tärjää ilman naista, he on aivan onnettomia kun he on nainen hoitamassa heitä.
Ehkä rakentaisi jonkinlaisen sillan tästä naisten asioiden hoitamista seuraavaan teemaan. Minä en kerron vain, että seuraavaksi pohdintoja ruokaan liittyen.
No heippa kansanradio, tää on aivan ihana ohjelmaa. Miel isnalta lähtee lenkillekään kun pitää kuunnella. Kuule sellainen juttu nyt on tuossa äsken kuuntelin siitä herneketosta. Ei ihmiset jaksa syödä niin paljon herneketoa, että siitä pierujaa tulee niin tää ilmastolämpiää. Tuo nyt oli kyllä aivan naurettava juttu. No kuinka paljon itse yleensä syöt herneketoa? No kuulee ihan vähän väliä ja ajattelin tuossa et eiköhän sitä purkita.
sie lähtee ostamaan tai sitten keitän ihan itse. Minusta se on ihan maailman parasta ruokaa.
- Ja etkä pelkää näitä päästöjä missä tässä ohjeessa oli kyse? - No kuule ei jos itse keittää niin ei siitä kuulettuu ilmavaivoja.
- No niin. - Niin ja sitten hernekettävä syyvää syökää ihmiset siitä tulee paljon proteiiniaa. Se on hyvä ruokaa.
- Kiitoksia paljon ja oikein hyvä sunnunta jatkaa. - No viitsi ja hyvää helluntaita.
- Sitä samaa. Hei hei. - No niin hei.
- No munamies täällä morjesta. Kyllä pitää vanhaksi elää ennen kuin hoksaa miten tuolla ihmisiä huiputetaan noissa elintarvikeostoksissa.
Nyt huomasin juuri yhdessä liikkeessä on kananmunat tavattomaa halpoja ja mä oon siellä juossu ja ostanu niitä ja kun mä paistan ne munat ja rikoon ne tuohon tuommoseen lettupannu niin se ei tule se pannu siitä munankosalta.
Ei tule edes täyteen ja jos mä ostan toisesta paikasta kananmunia ja rikoon niin mä joudun käyttämään lettupannusta kaksi sellaista syvän ettemmin ennen kuin ei nii mahdu yhteen ja nyt mä olen suvennut tarkkaan sitä niin se hintahan riippuu ihan siitä mikä se muna koko on. Tuossa on just mulla semmoinen rasija edessä kun kananmunat on kun peukalon väitä ja sitten kun mä otan jonkun toisen se on aika kumma juttu se on suljettu pakkaus jota on myynyt.
Hyvään kaupassa sen saa tietysti auki ja rahoittaa ja kattoo mut ei siinä missään sanota toiset on pieniä munia toiset on suuria munia ja ja ja periaatteessa ihminen tekee hinnanvertailun tietämättä lainkaan niin se on ihan erilainen paino ja kyllä tää se rupee tuon kaupassa käyntiin niin se rupee olla aika vaikea homma kun ei oikein tiedä kyllä meit kaikilla tavolla yritetään retkuttaa.
Kun tuotiin kaupasta kaksi ruisvarrasta molemmat olivat murentuneet niin pieniksi palasiksi että ei voinut pöytään laittaa viennällä ruista. Onko tarkoitus että nämä tehdään tällaisia ja olen moneen kertaan soittanut. He ovat tyytyväisiä kun annan palautetta mutta olen ainakin kolmestakymmenestä viiteenkymmenen leipää saanut puolen vuoden aikana tämmöisiä. Onko tai ikinä.
Kun on tässä vika vai paistossa no viimein he kyllä hyvittivät nyt sitten kuusi euroa että saan uutta leipää mutta ei kyllä vastaa niin mitä mä oon joutunut roskii eittämään että pitäisikö minun tässä kuluttaja asiamiehelle soittaa vai kenelle. Voisitteko joku neuvoa mitä tässä olisi tehtävissä. Heippa sinne ja nyt vielä kevätjuhlan kunniaksi jatkaamme koulumaailmaan.
Sitä kerron Kansanradion puhelinnumeron. Se on 0 8 0 0 1 5 4 6 4 ja puhelu on soittaajalle maksuton. Ja muistutuksena että sunnuntaisin kello kaksitoista kolmekymmentä alkaen tuossa numerossa vastaa ihmis vastaa ja kolmen tunnin ajan.
Aina pääsi lakin valvoisen saavutustasi ihailen taitan oksastaan ruusu muraisen. Sulle ojennan sinua onnittelen. Olkoon päiväsi ikimuistoinen. Tiesi kulkea turvallinen. Onnea kevään ylioppilaan.
Myöhemmä ja se tulee vähän lyhkeisemmä. Mä olen sitä mieltä että kyllä lapset tarvitsevat sen kesäloman pitkään kauan. Mutta toi yksi asia että heidän kesälomaan kun heillä on yli kaksi kuukautta kesän niin sitten kun se on kuukauden pois he rupesivat työntekijöihin niin kuin mukki ihmiset ja heillä on maanantaisinkin vapaa niin se on maananta työpäiväksi ja viisi päivän viikossa niin kuin mukki ihmiset. Heillä ei ole maanantatöihin ja tisdain tuo ja perjantaihin lähtee puolen päivän jälkeen.
Osa porukas tekee ja osa ei tee mitään että tää on aivan älytön tommoista. Luvetaan vaan ihan lasten koulu kesälomimulkkaamaan. Tää on aivan älytön tuo.
Vielä on ainakin luvassa ajatuksia lauluperinteestä. Ennen viimeisiä puheluita minä toivotan teille kaikkea hyvää. Koiviston Lauri kiittää ja kumartaa. Kansanradio jälleen viikon päästä.
Mihin on kadonneet suomalainen lauluperimme? Minua ihmetyttää miksi alle kolmekymppiset ei osaa ensimmäistäkään perimen laulua. Kukaan ei osaa niin minä niitonen sinulle laula kun kävelin kesä illalla. Kukkuu kukkuu kaukana kukkuu. No ei ole edes kovin vaikeita lauluja mutta tuntuu että koko lauluperimme on katolassa Suomesta.
No niin Malmo Boutilainen Kela ja Jyväskylä ja kolmas kesäkuuta nyt kaksituhatta kaksikymmentäkuusi on työttömän päivä globalisaatiossa ja köyhän ääri ei kuulu tarpeeksi niin otin tämmöisen vehkeen jotta minun köyhän ääri kuuluisi paremmin päin. Kiitoksia.
Nyt tää on ihan hullu juttu. Varokaa ulkomailla kun ootte kun on tietokoneita. Teitä voidaan sieltä kattoo jos siinä on kamera siinä tietokoneella. Teitä voidaan kattoo ja ne kuvat julkaistaan netissä. Mitä te siellä touhuvatte siellä huoneessa? Tää on tosi hullu juttu mutta näin voi käytä.